Oh
[Music]
Babel justice but Oh Spanish good oh
they're unable step on hand I knew that
yurina you will soon pay for what you
did to me there's no need to bother
really no I have no time to chat because
me max just run away and we'll be
waiting for you we do the waiting woman
won't it be waiting for me how would you
like to die pirate hanging hiring squirt
or your invents the guillotine
guillotine sounds French
I love the French did you know that they
invented mayonnaise how bad could it be
it's French hey
[Music]
oh let me aah
[Applause]
here's an idea here's an idea
oh why don't was regular fascist stoning
hang I killed mr. right now gets the
crowd involved doesn't it I should like
to speak to victim in disallowed
illegally partly I'm not one complaint
normally but this baskets full of heads
I'm looking for a buyer
Jack Sparrow I need to speak with you
Henry is sold either have a super
soldiers deliverance I'm Carolee what
reason yep so not a very good coming I'm
looking for a pirate - Captain Jack
Sparrow a today's your lucky day cuz I
just happen to be Captain Jack Sparrow
no it can't be
I've spent years searching for this the
great Jack Sparrow is not some drunk in
a Cell
do we even have a ship a crew pants a
great pirate does not require such
intricacies do you know how long I've
been waiting for this moment the risks
I've taken to be here you sure you're
the Jack Sparrow
[Music]
pirates had infected the seas for
generations
[Music]
so I filed preliminary the moment
[Music]
and then there was this boy
gets parole
follow him in
he took everything from me
and faceless
rate the dad I've taken the see girl
I've heard stories
the mighty Spanish captain whose son had
been killed thousands of men no no no
men no pirates pirates I once knew is
splendid then something in Spanish
he's coming future
where's your [ __ ] the crew
your pants Jackie I'm so sorry were you
still talking there's no word hide
find spy refer me
from this moment on we ought to be
allies
considering why your left hand is like
they were more than that
[Music]
thank you
I'm not looking for trouble horrible
Lena Lena
doing paying for what you did to me
little man shape I'm looking for Jack
I'm going to swim for it Kareena stop
this no no no no that's okay this has
gone far enough
no it has off I saw her ankles you just
seen a lot more if you kept your
cakehole shot
[Music]